hey guys i'm here to bring you a top
secret video of things you shouldn't
even know but you're gonna know anyway
hooked
okay i'm trying to give views all right
we're gonna make a c plus program with
visual studio code this is a question i
get a lot and it's how do you manage a c
plus plus project install the build run
and get all your buttons and stuff with
visual studio code and uh yeah okay i
guess my camera's reflected i don't know
where i'm pointing all right let's
launch visual studio code we're gonna do
it so
pre-requisites you're gonna need some
kind of c plus plus compiler it doesn't
really matter what kind
um i'm gonna use the visual studio one
which is ms build and i have a previous
video that explains that some in section
three i'll try to remember the link up
there so if you want to know more about
that you can but
uh we're also going to be using cmake
cmake visual studio code and that's
basically about it and we're just going
to say all right let's make a new file
select the language okay c plus plus so
we're starting from scratch oh my gosh a
file let's just make like a main
uh of course if you're writing software
you wanted to do something so that's up
to you to decide what you want to do
with the software we're just going to
make a hello world just to get a base
case up and do it
and when we go to save it i just press
ctrl s i need to give it a spot and this
is where we're going to start our
project so i'm going to go into one of
my storage drive source make a new
folder and call it
youtube vs code c okay that's like a
really long title all right go into
there
name this file main rather than untitled
one and there we go we now have a main
so
what's next
let's go to open a folder and we're
going to open this one we just created
that way it's going to give us the
directory over here you could do this in
reverse order you could create the
folder and then go to open folder and
then start doing your stuff however you
want to do it's fine
ah sip of coffee fellas if you'd like to
support me and help
buy me coffee you can do that and i
would appreciate it all right here we go
let's make a cmake list on text and with
this one of our extensions should kick
in so we're going to talk for a second
about extensions the only one i am using
is the microsoft cmake one here it is
cmake tools by microsoft that's like the
only extension i'm using you can use
more if you want but i'm not going to
make this real complicated and use a
bunch of random ones just the microsoft
c make tools and i have intellisense
from the microsoft one as well so we
need to design a basic cmake and we can
just type it in to make no suggestions
so we want this to be detected as a
cmake project we're gonna hit
the command ctrl shift p
and that brings up this whole command
thing for visual studio code we're gonna
start typing in cmake and there is a
cmake quickstart so we're just gonna
click that it's just going to fill some
code and advance for us and we can
choose what kit we want we're just going
to use
release 64. and it says we already have
a cmake file okay apparently you can't
do that when you already have a cma file
i just want the starter code
and if you can't get this quick start to
work or for whatever reason
you can just manually type in all this
stuff you're about to see making an
executable okay
so here's all you really need you need
the minimum required you need a project
name uh version's optional cool gives us
a version uh testing if you want we're
not going to do testing right now all
right and we have a cpac installer but
really all we want right now is this
executable the rest of this
we're not going to worry about i have
tutorials on all that stuff in my cmake
series if you want to check that out but
we just want to get the base case going
all right so we have this we have a main
this should already work but all cmake
does is it configures your build so it
looks like it did that automatically if
it doesn't do it automatically you need
to go to your terminal and of course do
the cmake commands that you need
but by default this extension that i'm
using the microsoft cmake tools will do
some of this stuff if you enable it so
we do know that once it's ready to be
built we can build it and the way we
build it is we use a compiler or we use
the make file so if we go to this build
we'll see that it has a bunch of visual
studio stuff in it zero check run test
package nightly
experimental i've turned off all this so
dart c test yeah we don't need to worry
about all that the only thing we
actually want is this one right here so
this actually might be a bit overkill
using this whole start thing but in any
real project you're probably going to we
want to use all those other features
anyway so it's fine so we have the
solution and we have this project we
basically need to compile those there's
a couple different ways you can do it
uh the first way is probably the default
way you want to open this directory so
right click on the file reveal and
explore and you'll see it here and you
can open this up with visual studio and
compile it it's going to have all the
settings from cmake that you specified
see it over here and right click build
put it built
see down here that it succeeded okay now
we can close this
close this so we have our out file it
should be in debug there it is there's
the executable so how do you launch this
well you can launch it from your
terminal just by doing you know the dot
slash
there we go yeah you do need to die all
right so hello world we ran it but what
if you just want a button well you can
do that we got a little run and debug
over here ctrl shift d and it creates a
json file when you try to run it so
let's go over this well let's create our
json and it asks you what environment
we're going to say windows because we're
on windows and it gives us this default
windows launch
what we want to do here is basically
make this go to our executable now we
can delete all this first text but we
have a workspace folder that's the
folder of our project and we know we
went to
build and then in this case debug the
name of our executable is youtube
youtube vs code cp so now it should
launch the right ones go back to the run
and debug hit the run button and it
launches in a terminal cool and you can
set up any amount of configs you want if
you have if you want special debugging
once for gdb or if you want to attach it
to a process you can do that it's a
little more advanced we're not going to
talk about that here so what next what
if you update your program and you want
to recompile or maybe you want to see
more options you can do with these
configs for example in this console you
just delete this
and hit control space to bring up this
uh
fill out thing you'll see some options
integrated terminal it's going to launch
it in the terminal down there so we hit
play and we'll see hello world
right here in visual studio so let's
talk about one other thing and that is
just rebuilding and making changes
all right say
let's just add like another let's just
make a function here
just put the hello world in it
so essentially the same program just
made some changes so that we have to
recompile
we'll save from function so it's obvious
that's using the new one that we built
and
yeah we should be able to just compile
this and re-run it but we can't just
compile it from visual studio right we
have to regenerate the cmake
well if we added a room files would have
to regenerate cmake but mainly we got to
open up this project again
and rebuild it with visual studio
right and that can be a pain so you
reveal open it yada yada or
you can just use your terminal here and
go
msbuild.exe
which is
essentially the same thing the visual
studio community edition does and then
path to this project which is
let's use forward slashes and no leading
one okay that worked fine so what that
did
was just build our software
so you can just do it like that you can
just run ms build and it's going to
build it with the config that you have
specified in your cmake file basically
whatever you generated that project with
and if you're using a different compiler
and generating for like ming gw or clang
or something well you'll know those
commands but essentially you can do the
same thing can you turn this into a
button that builds i am not entirely
sure
i couldn't find a way there's probably
add-ons that do it but i don't want to
get into trying out a bunch of add-ons
all right so this is for a console
program hopefully this answers all your
questions about how to get a c plus
program up and going with visual studio
code get the run button so that you can
just launch it and how to build it how
to set it up with some basic stuff let
me know if you have any questions
and
there's another version of this too
where if you're launching software that
has no terminal like windowed only and
like it's uh i don't know i'll do it
i'll do another version if this gets
like 50 likes so smash it
and smash my channel up into the sky
yeah
subscribe for more cheesy puns and more
code
see you guys next time
like and subscribe so i know to keep
making these kind of videos
you